[Applause]
[Music]
you may think our next presenter is here
because he won last year's award for
best supporting actor for a Fish Called
Wanda but you're wrong he's here because
he's the producers nephew so ladies and
gentlemen I give you the producers
nephew Academy Award winner mr. Kevin
Kline
[Applause]
thank you thank you members of the
Academy thank you distinguished guests
nominees uncle Gil although the first
Academy Awards were presented in May
19th on May 19th in 1929 it wasn't until
eight years later that Best Supporting
acting awards were finally given from
1937 up until this very moment there
have been 107 Oscar recipients for
supporting roles I'm very proud to be
here to help add another name to that
most distinguished list if I do say so
myself
this year the nominees for Best
Supporting Actress are Brenda Fricker in
my left foot Angelica Huston in enemies
lena olin in enemies a love story Julia
Roberts in steel magnolias Diane Reese
in Parenthood
and the Oscar goes to Brenda Fricker in
my left foot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't believe this I'd like to make a
private thank you to Byner and des and
inner burke and i'd like to thank every
single member of the crew who worked on
my left foot who created an atmosphere
of fun and love and hard work I'd like
to thank Christy Brown just for being
alive I'd like to thank mrs. Brown his
mother anybody who gives birth 22 times
deserves one of the least I think I'd
like to thank Jim Sheridan a chain
Connaughton for the best script I've
ever been involved in I'd like to thank
Nora Pierson for producing the film and
Jim Sheridan for just being the most
incredible director and the members of
the Academy for giving me this which I
would take very proudly with me back to
Ireland
[Applause]
[Music]
I've NSO announced at the lovely young
lady who presents me with the Oscars is
of course mr. salman rushdie continuing
what do you think guys good continuing
with our theme of nepotism famous
offspring a famous fathers are not
unusual in Hollywood John Carradine had
Keith and David Robert Redgrave begat
Vanessa a Michael Redgrave began Vanessa
and Lynn and of course Kirk Douglas gave
us Michael and James Buster Douglas
he hit me very hard he hit me very hard
I couldn't find my mouth beats good and
Lloyd gave us the Fabulous Baker boys
and here they are late and gentlemen
Jeff and Bob please welcome the fabulous
bridges boy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you good people we're here to tell
you about the next nominated film now a
lot of kids dream of growing up and
playing it on a major league ball team
right little brother exactly and ray
Kinsella was a big kid who never grew up
his dream was even bigger now this
fellow Ray dreamed of having his own
baseball diamond with his favorite ball
players playing right there and that
Iowa cornfield but - ray can sell it
wasn't just a dream it was real who
knows maybe we all have our own special
field of dreams true